i've liked i've tried to justify why i
like certain
power fantasies or such generic light
novel adaptations more than others
and i've just given up i'm just like
they're all trash i like this one i have
no idea why
and i i guess i'm just trash as well you
know
enough but like okay i i described it
the same way
that's you know i described the appeal
of light novels or how i perceive the
appeal of light uh
slice of life stories yeah so like why
do you like slice of life what's the
appeal to you because to me
how people view like these power fantasy
isekai or whatever shows is how i view
slice of life
to me they're all the [ __ ] same no no
they are and i i don't deny that because
i've i've gotten a lot of criticism in
the past being like
you like slice of life what you could be
doing anything else and yet you're
watching the fictional lives of these
fictional characters i'm just like
i think that's the part about it though
because it's like again when i watch an
anime
i'm thinking way too hard about it like
i always have to i'm always looking at
it like some kind of like
analytical like kind of like okay why do
i like the show why do i not like the
show
and slice of life just provides nothing
that that nothing becomes something you
know what i mean like
because this is getting you philosophy
yeah
it's like i've always i've always tried
describing like this because there's
nothing there that nothing becomes
something and like
that that thing because they're not
doing anything
everything they do becomes entertaining
because there's just nothing there to
begin with
yeah i can't do it i can't i can't i
can't maybe you should have been the
monk joey
yeah yeah man shave that hair joey let's
go
i don't know i mean maybe there's a part
of me as well that like the reason why
for example like i really
like uh non nonbioti right right it's
like because
it's set in like the middle of the
nowhere in like the [ __ ] middle of
nowhere of japan in the mountains right
yeah
where i grew up like at my grandma's
place was
it looked very similar yeah so i think a
lot of that kind of like atmosphere is
like
brings me back to like my childhood of
like just being in like the middle of a
rice field and just
trying to find anything to do yeah
entertainment sake right
and just watching these characters go
through that it's just like okay yeah
i can relate to that that's that's kind
of cute and like wholesome right because
like i think the only slice of life
i've enjoyed ever like pure slice of
life
and i think i can't even remember the
name it was the one with the two girls
going around the post-apocalyptic world
tour is it girls last time i got i can't
even yeah yeah yeah yeah girls last time
because that's one of my favorite slices
of life
yeah that's that's the only slice of
life i've ever enjoyed
and i still couldn't finish it really
yeah because
it i need to be in a very specific i
needed to be in like such a specific
mood
to watch that show and be able to like
not fall asleep it's
one of the most quietest shows i've ever
watched because a lot of the times
there's only these two girl characters
and there's almost
no [ __ ] like music or like background
it's very avant-garde it's like watching
a [ __ ] like
[ __ ] art school like project it's
like black and white and spoken in
french and it's like opposite of what i
want
yeah it looks and feels very pretentious
if you don't
understand like the deeper meanings
behind it yeah cause i feel like i need
the bare minimum of engagement for me to
enjoy a show
yeah even if it's just the same kind of
engagement i've seen a million times
before i will take that
over when i like used to watch shows
without looking what they were i would
just watch a show right unlike
crunchyroll i just click it and then i
i'm watching a slice of life and i get
two episodes and i'm like wait
nothing's gonna happen
they're not gonna do anything are they
why isn't that your like monkey brain
just like lags for a minute and it takes
you two whole episodes
hold on in this case i actually agree
with god you get like two episodes and
you're like
wait they're not gonna do a single thing
are they they're not gonna go
because i remember my i remember when i
first watched k on and like the k
on the the entirety of the k on fandom
hates me now because of that like one
review
that i did on k on because i didn't
understand the appeal of slicers life
back then yeah and i watched k
on with the same kind of expectations
like any other show and like people have
told me the appeal for karen and i
understand it now but i can never relate
to it yeah
i still can never get that same kind of
connection to a slice of life
that's why i don't blame anybody who
says that they don't like slice of life
like at all like
in any slice of life they'll just be
like nah it's all boring
nothing [ __ ] happens i'd rather be
watching like a shonen or something like
a generic show
i totally get that because again like
i i don't want to say it's an acquired
taste or anything but
i feel it is it isn't a question i'm
going to say the same thing about isa
guys
and that's okay man it's good man i'm
gonna say that about
like a documentary about something
that's real but even like a documentary
there's
i don't know it's a story it's still
still engaging yeah i feel like there's
stuff happened i feel like the closest
thing to rl's slice of life
is uh what's that japanese tv show
terrace house have you ever seen that
[ __ ] i can't watch terrorists
that's like slice of life irl yeah i
want to watch that and i'm like what's
the appeal it's like oh uh you can just
like watch them do
their daily things and have your
thoughts on it i'm like i could have
thoughts about my real life
it's the exact same reason why people
wanted to watch big brother right they
wanted to watch
like a [ __ ] show though like they i feel
like tara's house is very like
just polite they were all just like you
know i never watched it
i could never get into big brother
either though i could not do that
watching big brother just because the
people that they had on there were just
the most [ __ ] difficult
[ __ ] ways that was like finally
selected together yeah yeah yeah
craziest people they could find i was
like these i'm like i can't believe
these are not real people
and then i and then later i found out
that the entire show is scripted i'm
like oh that makes a lot of sense
yeah i mean it's it's uh they they
obviously put a lot of work behind the
scenes to make
it entertaining yeah whereas i think i
feel with tara's house it's just
here are just people living their lives
yeah and there's a camera watching them
and i just took it why that's fun i just
don't get it
maybe i'm too many people there's there
was i'm wearing dude
on this one i'm like my own life to
worry about
[ __ ] worry about people just having
an awkward conversation i can experience
that myself there was a moment there was
a show that uh preceded uh
terrace house and i don't know if it's
still going or not but it's called
and uh and there was a show that's kind
of similar to tara's house where but
there was like a romance element
it's essentially think of a harem anime
irl
that's that's the only way i can
describe it so they would like like love
island or some [ __ ] like
something like it's similar to that but
like they would get like a bunch of guys
and girls like single guys and girls
and they put them on this bus and they
would take the bus and they would
basically
just do like an entire tour of japan
like wherever the [ __ ] they wanted but
at every stop
one of the guys or the girls had to like
confess basically to be like i like you
and if they responded back positively
then the bus would leave the two there
and then basically just let them you
know nowhere yeah but sometimes it was
but it was harsher when the other person
denied it because then the person who
confessed would be left there basically
on their own and just
watching like a guy or a girl get denied
on that show
was the most heart-wrenching yet somehow
the most [ __ ] entertaining thing that
you've ever seen
because it's just like is he gonna
because it was it was like a harem anime
where like
one of the best goals is like getting
prepared to like confess
come on i've seen you like go camping
with this dude man like you gave off
some good vibes you got this girl you
got this and then when the guy's like
no sorry there's another girl that i
like and the sad music just starts
playing i'm just like
it's like it's like watching your you
know going back to the whole sports
thing right yeah
it's like watching the grand finals and
the one team just like
flopping it at the last second you know
it's like no that's
the game yeah but i i prefer that over
terrace because i gave tara's house a go
i don't know it's it would seem like on
paper because i like slice of life right
yeah it would seem like this is a show
made for me right
okay so okay here's here's how here's
what confuses me do you have a favorite
slice of life
and how do you justify that i don't know
i mean because so many shows can be
defined as slice of life shows and yet
they're not
right i mean like a lot i i don't know i
guess lucky stuff will probably be my
favorite
just because it goes memes yeah because
of the maymays right because because
it's just
because it appeals to the otaku culture
right and like that was a huge part like
that was like when i was like deeply
rooted in otaku culture right so that
that anime spoke to me dude it hit
different
that was
that's probably my favorite for those
reasons yeah